what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to a clip
oh [ __ ] my bad bro i know using a
recording video
my bad bro i just wanted to show you
some you stop recording
you ain't stop recording that nah don't
stop it don't stop it don't stop it
look look i just can't show you this
that's fire yeah yeah
you excited about me why are you really
excited come on
baby i'm so happy for that opportunity
i'm very proud of you
that's what i'm talking about yes sir
i'm very proud of you you're so
successful
but you know when i'm filming a video
right listen i ain't know
bro that's what i'm saying but you did
yeah i ain't no i know i know you're not
deaf
i know i know i know you're not deaf i
mean listen
i heard you right before i walked in but
at the time my hand was oh don't stop it
i heard you right before i walked in but
at the time
my hand went on the doorknob and i was
already in motion right so
i hear you well listen it's exciting
news this is very exciting and you can
keep this in here they gonna find this
entertainment okay do you want to tell
them what you found out
why don't you talk
listen i'm gonna be in tick tock
commercials and advertisements and yeah
yeah yeah
he's so talented thank you man listen
that's all i want to do
thank you that's all i'm going to just
celebrate your family
my bad i'm going to get out of your head
okay
all right love you too
but let's remember listen when the door
is closed we listen
see if i'm recording
oh my god he's so irritated
okay um before
but for real this just came out
[Music]
i heard you called me irritated though
so i had to do it
he is irritating he's so irritated
and stop playing on me though bro i can
do this all day oh god i can do this
all day stop playing okay just leave it
alone okay all right
okay give me something okay
he does this all the time it's so
annoying like literally so annoying i
have to restart
[Laughter]
okay so i can't stop laughing okay
um so i'm gonna be reacting to a video
that somebody sent me
um on my instagram so if you guys
already know
um i accept video dms like on instagram
so if you have a video you think it'd be
good for me to react to sending to me on
instagram
this is like a youtuber
oh wait aiden
ross asks this z should he cheat on
pampy baby and he explains why he should
cheat on her
seems interesting enough okay
let's go
i don't know are you saying that's what
you have right now
yeah you know no i just like this girl a
lot
you'll meet her you want to marry her
who knows what will happen would you
cheat on her
never you never cheat on her never
just would you have a kid wait why is he
why is he so shocked wait
what it's necessary
wow i feel like it's important to cheat
like at least twice a month
well when he puts it like that
i hope my boyfriend cheats on me yeah
so i i like her yeah because it makes
you like appreciate like
right oh my gosh
what i'm saying you might start not
appreciating her as much as you did
oh sometimes you gotta you gotta you
gotta slain that
you gotta slam that dick around it's a
variety of women
to keep you keep your brain sharper you
know to make
make your feelings better who you really
love got it
damn what the [ __ ] i didn't put it like
that
i'll say two three but you know research
my research
yeah his research
wow just once but i say two to three
oh right little variety i get it
so so so so so basically
if i ever get into a relationship with
the next person i'm seeing you recommend
i do cheat
at least two three times a month a month
don't go up
don't go over okay
well when he puts it like that
if you find out your man's cheating on
you say thank you
say thank you say
you know what baby i know you did it to
get closer to me
i wonder if i like her so much to cheat
i'm telling you that life is going to
fade a little bit you're going to start
under appreciating her so you you have
to go out and cheat you have to go [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you have to go get some head like you
feel what i'm saying you know
you around your [ __ ] all the time bro
yeah and that that time that that moment
when you get tired of her bro
you got to go [ __ ] another [ __ ] to
remind you like damn i miss my [ __ ]
that makes sense what if i
oh my god i just thought of something he
is okay
no chat listen what if this
what if i just giving hell advice
no listen i actually have an idea it's
like 50 50. let's say i fall in love
with his next girl
i love her right what if i [ __ ] guys
listen oh technically not cheating
because i'm not attracted to guys
does that make sense
what do you mean it's making a lot of
sense
i'm trying to explain it to you so
listen it's not cheating so go gay in
order to cheat i'm not attracted bro
that's gay
[Music]
right right king right
no come over here what is going on bro
come here bro that's gay bro
you know so look all right all right but
look listen
forgot this [ __ ] let me ask you a
question have you ever been in a
relationship before
of course what was your longest
relationship you've ever been in two
years
and what happened uh
we not together what happened though it
was in college he moved he graduated he
was over here
so you moved away she moved away
otherwise you guys are big together
right now
why not did you stop liking her
too i like how he says that's so
nonchalantly so
the when first
made it we made it official
i teach it the next day yeah
look at him i feel bad
all right oh poor guy i was like okay if
i tell her
honestly with that situation i feel bad
for him
what is his name aidan or zias you know
i i feel bad for him poor guy
can't imagine being in that situation
but
moving forward i already cheated
so he had to cheat crazy like get more
right right by the way
yeah yeah i'm not going to tell her i'm
not you know saying just keep cheating
right so i just kept cheating right um
[Music]
i loved her though you loved her my love
was strong bro
when you when you cheat when you cheat
do you do
drink before do you feel less guilty or
not
no sober
i was [ __ ] [ __ ] on her bed
wait so look at this look at his face
look at his face your girlfriend's
x's girlfriend's bad you [ __ ] other
girls
good chair did you ever find out
god damn um
you know honestly i think he had to hook
up with those girls on his bed i bet his
bed
wasn't made right he didn't want to
bring girls back to an unmade bed so he
had to bring them back to his
girlfriend's bed it only makes sense
let me ask you a question this is
totally oh
hold on this is a long time ago this is
like fun
so yeah i'm not i'm not bragging about
this this is that's [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah he's just yeah yeah
you're not like saying like
yeah that was when i was young and dumb
i was you know i wasn't really i
wouldn't do that now though
no yeah i know you're like you wouldn't
even get yeah do you want you want to do
a relationship or not right now
i'm i'm cool right now you're chilling
yeah yeah i got you i got you
oh can i just try can i touch your hair
what i'll touch it
why do you want to touch it because it's
cool looks nice in a not a weird way can
i just touch it
no bro it looks
no okay all right um
so um
why don't we uh you want to want to
start freestyling and watching [ __ ]
now you have a free throw hell yeah not
a freestyle
where is billy pulling up or he's not
pulling up anymore now he's pulling up
how far is blue
i like how they just assume he can't
freestyle you never know maybe he's
really good
i'm gonna give him another chance
hey how you doing good how are you good
good
um where are you from
cool cool uh how old are you
28
he probably had to i mean he's getting
ready to like switch over to guys
what's your brother's name nick
bro nick bro why are you [ __ ] blocking
never mind she's capping she's been
watching the whole time
she likes him she's been watching she's
capping
l nick in the chat wait out nick in the
chat
anyways um yeah
what's up with madden brother do you
even play man so now
we are going to do a wager me and then
when you when you start shipping on
twitch you'll be on my ssb world and we
can do a matter with you
i'm not gonna start streaming you just
said you were i'm just talking like
i i doubt i'm gonna stream like i'm not
that's that's not an energy
it is a lot of hours
i know you are i know you are you so let
me ask you a question do you like
youtube
do i like youtube you have fun doing
your youtube [ __ ]
not as much as i did before not you lost
kind of like passion for it
i'm still passionate about it i still
it's not as fun
uh i don't know how to explain it
i got on youtube and it's like an escape
from a certain
from what i was dealing with at the time
we were going through some [ __ ]
so i got on youtube you know
flying kind of brings that it's weird i
want to talk about that though
okay we can talk about it later um
all right let's pop on a beam freestyle
[ __ ] it
that's like a pretty hard drug right
perk percocet you're done eating
you know you're gonna eat after me bro
what's wrong with that
yeah i wouldn't care oh look at his face
look at his face
sorry okay let's pop out a beat um
okay
you know the way that he described it i
feel like he had to cheat
like clearly he wanted to really be in
love with his girlfriend
so he had to have [ __ ] over i
let me know in the comments if you agree
or you disagree do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
ring that notification bell and i'm
gonna talk to you guys
next time